I was wondering if you have any experience with using
right-for-issures such as skin cancer, heart-related conditions and stabilizing blood pressure.
Well, you could call our office and who will most likely answer
is Marina and she will talk to you about using the right-for-heart issues
because I've written programs for her for that.
But there are programs under right-for-a-lot of things.
So understand, the knife is a tool.
So you have to use a tool correctly.
You don't use a screwdriver to pound in a nail.
You could do it, but it's not going to be very effective.
The same thing with the right.
The right is using light-for-requencies.
Let's say I am mercury toxicity.
I'm going to use a knife-ishing to detox mercury.
Well, it's not going to do anything to key-late mercury out of your body.
Well, could I run liver programs?
Would it help my liver function better?
Yes, yes it would.
So indirectly it's going to help with that.
It's not going to pull mercury out of the tissues to get to the liver,
but it could help your liver work better.
Could I run it on my kitty to help my kitty function?
Yeah, well for sure.
Yes.
Could I kill skin cancer with it?
Yes, you can.
But there's different types of skin cancer.
So the question was, if you have experience, you see the right for skin cancer.
Yes.
So the more deadly skin cancer is the most deadly is melanoma.
So the three most common skin cancers are melanoma that can be the most deadly squamous cell,
which could also be deadly and then basil cell, which is rarely, rarely deadly.
So if a person calls and does a case review with me and they have basil cell cancer,
would I recommend the right for she?
Well, it really depends on their budget.
So honestly, if you don't have any cancer and you just want a good healing tool for your house,
I would highly recommend the right for she.
It can be good for all sorts of things.
So I don't have any skin cancer.
What do I have?
I have kids.
My kids get colds or I don't have kids, but I get colds.
I want to stay healthy, especially in this environment where I'm kind of the one or one of the doctor anymore.
The right for she can be a great tool.
Comes with, you know, 2500 different programs from anything from macular degeneration to headaches,
to inflammation, swelling, to viruses, to bacteria, to just whatever thing you could think of.
But it's going to work better on different things.
So it's going to work better on killing living things.
It's going to work better on bringing frequency, harmony to your tissues.
So it can help all your organs work better.
But it really shines when you're trying to kill something living.
You're trying to kill cancer cells.
You're trying to get your immune system to attack a cancer cell.
It can kill bacteria and viruses and pathogens directly because they are not as stable molecules.
So not as stable organisms.
Let's take viruses out of that classification.
But viruses technically are really living their only reproduce when they get inside your cell.
But it can help stimulate your immune system to attack that virus and kill that virus.
That's what we need.
So it can be a great tool for, so answer the first question.
Yes, it can be a great tool for skin cancer.
If a patient calls and they have squabble cell or melanoma, absolutely you got to get a right fishing.
If you have basal cell, well, will a right fishing help?
Yes, but I do think you should do other things topically to basal cell cancer.
So there's also, it's indifferent therapies that you could use for a basal cell cancer that we have used for essential oils to curcumin cream that we make in our office.
There's some things that you can, that you can purchase.
There's a B17 topical cream that we have in our store and there's some other skin topical creams that people could use as well.
As far as using the right for heart related conditions, yes, it can be extremely helpful.
Remember heart related conditions, I would highly recommend if you have any heart related conditions,
whether people have high blood pressure or a history of any type of intertheal disorder,
to make sure that you go on our website and search for H. Pylora and read and watch some, read those blogs
and watch some of the videos that I created at H. Pylora because H. Pylora is a major player with heart conditions.
Also look at possible Lyme disease and heavy metal toxicity.
There are three major players that are causes of blood pressure and heart disease.
All of all kinds are H. Pylora, Lyme disease, heavy metal toxicities and other product infections that could get under the intertheality to affect the receptors of the muscles that cause constriction of the muscles.
So that's what causes high blood pressure.
So look at that as well. But the right is a fantastic killer of anything.
Lyme like I said, so you should be ready to H. Pylora and frequency.
So if you already have a right and you have these conditions, you should be ready.
There's blood pressure program on the right, there's skin cancer programs.
I think on the right and there's definitely H. Pylora on the right that you should be ready for those programs.